en france maintenant l'accident de
l'airbus a320 adam shine il y a tout
juste un an qu'on à vol de démonstration
les rapports ont été rendus publics
aujourd'hui il en ressort qu on est
peut-être allé un petit peu trop vite en
besogne en dénonçant l'attitude des
seuls pilotes l'accident en fait serait
dû à toute une série de négligences
jean-pierre quinson et le reportage de
fr3 phrase le 26 juin 88 un airbus a320
en démonstration s'échoue en bout de
piste de l'air au club des prime
l'accident fait trois morts et de
nombreux blessés
un premier rapport préliminaire va
innocenté l'avion et retenir des charges
importantes contre les pilotes
les deux rapports d'experts remis
aujourd'hui par le juge d'instruction
marie catherine marchionni aux parties
civiles
blanchi à nouveau l'avion mais partagent
les responsabilités
ce que j'entends aujourd'hui c'est que
la responsabilité du commandant asseline
par exemple ne serait pas aussi engagée
que celle d'autres qui vont être
inculpés et on nous annonce de
nombreuses inculpation concernant les
compagnies aériennes voire des
fonctionnaires de la direction générale
de l'aviation civile reste des zones
d'ombré dans l' enquête selon certains
témoignages les boîtes noires ont été
soustraites après l'accident
pendant plusieurs jours à la justice les
pilotes accusés ont déclaré pour leur
part que certains enregistrements
avaient été truqués et puis aujourd'hui
le responsable de l'instruction au début
de l' enquête déclarent avoir été
l'objet de pressions ont été faites à
partir
dommage politique parisienne et avec un
relais implantée à la préfecture
territoriale au plus haut niveau au plus
haut niveau
le ministre des transports a fait savoir
aujourd'hui qu'il allait sans doute
porté plainte contre ce qu'ils
estimaient être des diffamations